Google Cloud updates system insights is
a database system monitoring tool that
brings together critical metrics events
and logs to provide a comprehensive view
of both external database performance
and internal system resources all in a
single dashboard meaning you can quickly
identify potential sources of problems
without having to switch between tools
have you heard of our no cost gamified
learning experience that features new
games every month the arcade has games
based on labs from Google Cloud skills
boost so you can get hands-on experience
with Google Cloud's powerful AI tools No
Quarters required and you can even earn
points for swag check it all out on the
blog and we'll see you next week for
more